- Is it true Sandi,
you also worked three jobs at one...?
I mean, how...?
- I've always worked three jobs.
'Cause I put him in private school.
I sent him through college.
He played tennis, which
is not a cheap sport.
(audience chuckle)
But, I wanted him to have
everything I didn't have, so.
(audience applauds)
- We saw your pride, you know,
just as you beep beep went by.
(everyone laughs)
What does it feel like to
have all that hard work
that you put into raising him, pay off?
I mean, the man he's
become is because of you.
What's that like?
- I'm very, very proud
of the man he has become
because, you know,
you see so many people that
don't put in the effort
and I just like to see my reward.
Because, when I even see him on camera,
it could be like a 20-second block,
but I'm just beaming,
because he's doing what
I was wanting to do,
I went to school for journalism.
I raised him. He's doing it.
So, I'm living for him.
(audience applauds)
(audience whoops)
- Sandi, is it true you
haven't taken a vacation
in five years?
- I had a broken ankle.
I had to go through four surgeries.
So I've been home for
almost four or five years.
This is my nurse right here.
- [Ross] Oh.
- Well, I heard that you were
interested in going to Cabos.
Is that true?
- Oh my God, that's my favorite place.
- [Drew] Is that your dream place?
- Yes. That's my dream place.
- [Drew] Have you ever been?
- Yeah, I have.
But I've always wanted to take him.
- [Drew] So you guys
have never gone together?
- I've never been out the country before.
- [Drew] Well, pack your bags,
(Sandi gasps)
because we are gonna give you
an all inclusive trip -
- [Sandi] Oh my God!
(audience applauds and cheers)
- to the brand new Villa La Valencia
Beach Resort and Spa in Cabos!
- [Sandi] Yes way. Yes way!
We're gonna give you $1,000 spending money
because you know, I don't know,
maybe you need a new suit
and like some chocolates,
and you know, some sunblock
and stuff for that.
(Sandi laughs)
- Oh my God. Thank you so much!
(audience cheers and applauds)
- [Ross] Congratulations.
- And let this be the beginning
of a beautiful friendship please.
- [Myles] Yes, please.
- [Ross] Congratulations Sandi.
(audience cheers and applauds)
So happy for you!
- Myles and Sandi, welcome to the show!
It is literally built for you.
Thank you so much. Let's do more.
Let's play, and we wanna
hear all about Cabos.
(theme music plays out)